on se posait la question comment sortir
les 75 à 100 milliards d'euros départ en
force et qui ont été accumulées ces
derniers tombent à peut-être que pour ça
il faut pas faire qu'une politique de
l'offre mais faire aussi un peu une
politique de la demande dans le plan de
relance de ce condensé aujourd'hui il
n'y a aucune baisse de tva
contrairement à l'allemagne qui va
baisser sa tva qui va baisser sa tva
d'ailleurs et qui l'avait déjà fait de
manière un peu ciblées par exemple sur
les billets de train pour relancer le
transport par le train dans une optique
de transition écologique de on a on n'a
pas non plus de relance du point
d'indicé qui est gelé depuis dix ans on
a pas on n'a pas voilà on a on a une
épargne forcée qu'on va à aider à se
débloquer pourquoi les gens aujourd'hui
ne ne consomme pas c'est pas parce que
c'est pas à cause de l'équivalence
ricardienne c'est pas parce qu'ils ont
peur que demain leurs impôts augmentent
c'est parce que tout simplement il n'y a
pas de perspective et si on fait qu'une
politique de l'offre et que les
entreprises n'ont pas plus de
perspective demain d'avoir des débouchés
d'avoir des marchés tout ça ne servira
pas à grand chose et ça ne comblera pas
l'écart avec les autres pays
[Musique]